france gall l'a révélé hier elle a subi
une intervention chirurgicale le 22
avril dernier
les médecins sont optimistes car le
cancer a été découvert à temps mais pour
l'instant la chanteuse doit suivre un
traitement particulièrement fatigant
gérard dalmaz grande était la complicité
avec le rêveur toujours de passage
michel berger son compositeur des poules
et france gall très grande a été sa
peine le 2 août dernier lors de la
disparition brutale de michel début de
la solitude la fin des rêves
ce choc psychologique de l'été 92 avant
certaines thèses a pu être le détonateur
de la tumeur au sein de france gall par
une baisse de ses défenses immunitaires
vue de l'esprit réplique des
cancérologue réputé rien n'a jamais pu
être démontrée entre le chagrin le
veuvage et la déclaration d'un cancer
il n'en reste pas moins que la star
femme enfant caché beaucoup de courage
exemple tout frais la réalisation de ce
cd manuel chang
une performance à deux titres mercredi
et jeudi derniers d'abord seulement 24
heures pour sortir ce disque
ensuite parce que france pour
l'enregistrement au théâtre de paris
sortait de sa deuxième séance de rayons
sur les six prévus france avait même
bonne figure il est vrai que la maladie
était prise à temps et qu'il n'y a pas
une ablation le petit caporal fait face
comme aurait dit son père france brûle
déjà de retrouver les planches de bercy